a family united in grief and in duty
king charles with his sister princess
anne and brothers prince andrew and
prince edward joined once more to stand
vigil over their mother's coffin
and here to lend support camilla queen
consort
and other members of the extended royal
family
this has been the most demanding of
weeks a relentless royal schedule
allowing little time for reflection
[Laughter]
their loss is deeply personal but here
for a few minutes at least it was shared
by a morning public
who came to pay their respects to a
queen
but also
found the king
we set off from huddersfield at two this
morning so it has been a long day but
just for those three two three minutes
they're so special
it's yeah it's just they just hold
themselves with such dignity more than
what i expected you know so emotional
yes and so special is a kind of
momentous
moment in
british history it's hard enough for
everybody to grieve privately when they
have that kind of loss but for them to
grieve so publicly just puts so much
extra pressure on them so i think they
handle it amazingly well
this tradition is known as the vigil of
the princes
princess anne is the first woman to
stand guard
tonight prince andrew has been allowed
to wear his royal navy uniform a
privilege removed after the scandal of
his association with disgraced financier
jeffrey epstein
the king has been widely praised for his
messages of unity
and ahead of tonight's vigil
he reaffirmed his belief
in a united multi-faith kingdom i've
always thought of
britain as a community of communities
that
has led that has led me to understand
that the sovereign has an additional
duty
less formally recognized but
to be no less diligently discharged
it is the duty to protect the diversity
of our country including by protecting
the space for faith itself
on saturday there will be another vigil
for another generation of mourners
all eight of the queen's grandchildren
a fitting tribute to a queen whose love
of country
was matched only by her love of family
ashish joshi sky news
in westminster